Hello everybody, my name is Markiplier and welcome to Loved...
I am a man!
At least as far as i know and as far as I've convinced you gu-
Oh
OHHHH
It's gonna be *that* type of game
Ohhhh I see how this is gonna go
Will I teach you how to play or not?
Well I don't know if this little girl wants to cooperate!
But sure
Teach me your wise ways
Oh
Oh, I do not deserve it
Oh okay
And there was something else there
Alright, so...
Not that you will cont- control *presses control*
You are- I am wrong *laughs*
I just hit control, what more do you want from me?
Okay dickhole!
We're gonna play this game by your rules apparently...
So this is a game about choices...
And, "Jump over that pit of barbs"
Ok
This is what I'm assuming- it's kind of like a Stanley Parable-type thing...
But this game actually came out before The Stanley Parable.
This was in 2010
So I imagine...
*confused* It's not even a pit of barbs...
I mean I know where-- euegh-- aw DISGUSTING?
But I thought I was a pretty little girl-- Oh God!
Is that a platform? Oh...
Ah
Well that's not good.
Oh that's probably not good, Or maybe it is good...
*comedic sounds of exertion*
Oh!
Oh okay I guess that does--does nothing...
He already knows or she, I don't know who. They already know that I'm disgusting.
HEUG, Oh, Oh-ch Oh, oops UH, Don't look at just what happened the game-oh
*Pauses* Ahhhhhh.
So, yeah.
I don't know what this has to do with being loved,
But, I have no idea.
Touch the statue, I will forgive you...
How about no?
When the first time I played the Stanley Parable I said "no" a lot, too.
Oh geez, *chuckle*
I'm a disappointment! But I don't wanna be!
Ooh- ah! Shit!
Okay...
I got neither praise nor admonishment, so I'm gonna assume that was okay.
Alrighty then... Travel the lower path..
*laughs* Well, the lower path seems to be filled with death...
Aww geez... I'm disgusting, ugly, and a disappointment... Boy I sure do feel loved.
*Laughing* Oh man... Oh I feel loved. Okay.
So what- uh. Whatever.
Ah shit!
Oh ge- *realization* Oh! I should've touched the thing!
Oh I'm an idiot! Well, I'm not gonna go the lower path this time...
My desire to be loved shall not outweigh my lazi- Ah shit.
Well, it's a good thing I- yeah, thank you.
Alright... God Dammit! I am an idiot.
Yeah you better spit me out the wrong way... I- oh come on!
Why is this so hard to do? I'm just trying to thread this needle here...
Oh you sack of tits! I'm not doing this on purpose!
Okay... We're gonna, by little increments of minutia... Okay.
*Deep breath*
The problem is, whenever I play these platformer- type games, I'm always in a hurry.
And I don't know why- "Throw yourself into the barbs?"
Why would you want that?
That seems like a bad thing.
I don't need to be loved that badly.
Oh, you're disappointed in me! Who ca- oh.
What is that?
*startled/confused* Do I own your body or your mind?
How about neither?
*Sounds of disgust*
Well, I guess, isn't there a famous quote?
That you can take my body but you'll never take my mind or break my wi- I don't know.
The body? *More sounds of disgust*
*Laughs* Dance for me. Okay!
*Begins singing an unidentifiable tune* - Oh God, I'm supposed to disobey.
How am I supposed to dance? Can I touch this?
Is that dancing? Uh-oh.
I don't know. Oh- things are getting really, wonky on the... uh... color-pixelated stylings of this.
*Noises akin to throat singing*
Okay. *More noises*
Gotta watch out for this!
*Again, the noises continue*
Do not move, how about screw you?
I'm disgusting... ah... oh... that was cheap.
You're cheap.
Ah- this is gonna take forever. I'm not good at chang- oh!
I take that all back, I- I- *Noises of uncertianty* I am the best.
Okay... Do not touch the statue. Well screw you! That's me! Little miss disappointment.
I know, I know.
Oh God, what am I- woah. Is that coming after me?
Hey! Back off! Stranger danger!
Oh geez, it's getting- it's getting bad in here.
*Strange noise*
Oh, I slammed groin-first into it.
Did it shake and spit me back out? Did I see that right?
*Melodically* Oh noooo!
Oh God- race against the clock.
I'm not stressed enough for this.
I'm really curious as to why- oh, that's a biggen.
Oh it's a- ahh! Come on!
Ohh! It's so far back!
God dammit! Okay...
Get serious here, I'm trying to make jokes and I'm not actually thinking about this properly.
Actually, I wasn't even making a joke then! I was actually trying to contemplate the world and what's going on in here.
And then I- And then I saw a big one and I- oh, it wasn't even coming towards me!
It was- it was- it was a stationary one! I panicked for nothing!
Ah geez... *noises of exertion*
Okay... soon we will see each other...
Well I have a funny feeling it's not going to be a happy re- oh.
Are you excited? Or frightened?
Well I don't know if this makes a damn difference!
How about... exfrighted?
How about... *tries other combinations of excited and frightened*
Excited!
... So am I... ooh... I- uh... woo.
Is that some kink I hear in your voice?
Do not fail.
Uh... *laughs* shit.
I tripped and I fell *laughing*
What can I do?
Do not fail...
Ah! Again with the failure!
How am I supposed to be able to do this... and disobey?
Maybe I shouldn't have hit "excited"...
Maybe I should've hit frightened... I don't know.
I don't know if anything would've made a difference there.
I don't know... like... ahhh! Come on!
I don't know how many endings are in this game.
Woo geez...  Woo geez! Hoo! Oh! Hey!
Hey friends! Woah! Okay! Goodbye!
See ya... See you guys... Weeee!
I did it!
I *chuckles* did it!
I- oh. Why do you hate me? Uhh...
I don't know... I loved you. I- I- I don't think so.
Where will you go? Will you be close to me?
Uhh... I gotta- I've got an appointment...
I beg you to stay?
Man, you don't call someone ugly and disgusting and expect them to stay!
At least, I don't.
Ohh... this is weird.
This is getting weird.
Oh!
O- Oh!
Okay, that's the end then.
Alrighty...*laughs* I guess...
I guess in the logical sense of it, if I left, then I just left! Holy crap.
Okay, let me try this again...and I'm going to...
Do it a different way. *proudly* I'm a woman!
I'm a strooong independent woman!
I'm a boy. Oh.
Well we're off to a killer start here, will I teach you how to play? How about not?
You will fail. Well, I've already been through that before, so I think I'm gonna be okay.
But this time, I'm rearing and ready to obey.
Mmm'kay. Jump over that pit of- oh!
Oh!
It was a pit of barbs...
He wasn't lying to me...
Statue? I will forgive you?
Thank you!
*Chuckle* I'm a good boy!
Oh, that's so cool!
Oh, wow, like, legitimately...
Travel the lower path... okay...
I had no idea!
I didn't even know that's what was happening! I didn't know...I didn't know that the world was... devolving like that.
Oh!
*Laughs* That's legitimately really cool!
Eah!
Aw man... Oh... this is the part that vexed me before...
But I'm okay... Ahh! Oh! I got vexed!
They vexed all over me!
Make it through, make it through, yeah, there we go. *Strange noises*
There we go.
Throw yourself into the barbs... Okay this is where I kinda question things but okay!
I'm a good boy! That me! It that good boy!
Oh... Oh that's so cool!
To go by the old Markiplier cliche, that's so cool!
Oh, that's awesome!
Do I own your body or mind? How about the mind? Can't beat this sexiness.
Beg for me.
Again, this doesn't feel a whole lot like love...
But uh... what do I know?
I'm just an a-amo-amorphous blob.
Is like the end of this once I get through all of this, am I gonna be like the last one that gets detail?
Because I seem to be like a shadow...
So it would make sense that there's something going on here.
How do... I'm not moving!
How can I beg if I cannot move?
How can I dance if I cannot move?
I'm a good boy, you just needed to wait for me to load in the game.
*Sounds of panic*
Ohh, I made it
*More unintelligible sounds*
Okay, I made it.
Do not touch the statue. You got it, bub!
Ready to please, bub!
Ooh, how about this statue? Good boy.
That me. It that good boy.
Okay... man, this is a... this looks a lot nicer...
Now that it's- ugh, I did the same thing again, I slapped my balls across that spike!
Owie!
Are those- Are those eyes and a mouth in the walls there? I'd like to think they're not, but...
I can't help shake the feeling that they is...
Yerp... Yerp... Oupp!
*Strange sounds*
Alright! Soon we will see each other.
*Deep breath*
Are you excited? Or frightened?
I'm... pretty frightened...
Then it will only be more enjoyable. For me or you?
What does that mean? That's... that's weird.
Still kinky, but weird.
I will not fail.
I will *not* fail. Woah, I almost failed.
Oh, I'm an idiot. I almost failed.
*Strange noises*
Okay..
Don't fail, don't fail. Don't mess up, don't mess up.
Okay. Don't mess up. I'm good. I'm good. I'm good. I'm good. I'm good.
I did it! I did it! I did it! Yeah! I did it!
Okay, cool!
I'm so happy that you are mine.
Yay! What are you? Who are you?
Are you a boy, or a girl? I'm a good boy!
I'm a good boy!
I'm a- oh!
I'm a man!
I'm a man! Oh! I loved you always!
Oh! There's more! Oh, there's more.
Oh, more trials and tribulations for me to endure.
Ooh, what is that?
What is this? *gasp*
What does this mean? What does that mean? What does that mean? What does that mean? What does that mean?
I don't know what that means. Oh...
I like that! I like that. I like that a lot. That is cool.
That. Is legitimately cool.
There's a lot of, like, questionable elements about it, like, who was that person? Who was I?
Was that my inner monologue? Was that maybe the thoughts inside my head?
Was it another situation like the park where I made up the environment in my own mind...?
And the only thing I was running away from was myself? Not to get all existential about it, but I'm just kinda spitting out ideas here and there.
But that was cool. That was legitimately cool. Okay.
I'll put a link down in the description below if you find anything else in this game, maybe there's more than just two endings to this...
Maybe there's, like, a middle road there,  but either way...
Thank you all so much for watching, and as always, I will see you in the next video. Bye-bye!